you cannot transcend by talking about it  intellectual conversation is wonderful  it's amazing it really is important for  us as humans to bond and connect and be  inspired and then there is a whole other  universe of transcendence that happens  in the processes of technique i worked  with somebody today who came to me who  said you know my i feel like my life has  almost passed me by and i have failed to  access the spiritual part of who i am  get on the mat  develop a meditation practice and given  the space  humans are connected to their  spirituality we are truly i heard you  say it recently i'm a spiritual being  having a human experience right and